hey guys welcome to another et live I'm
Hallie Stevens and I'm so excited
because today we have a sure angel in
studio I know that you guys are excited
too so send me all of your comments I
know you have burning questions get them
in there I'll try and get them answered
for you in the meantime we have to talk
about your new music cuz it is so good
what was the inspiration behind
chemistry the inspiration behind
chemistry well you know I've been a huge
Michael Jackson fan my entire life like
I watched it his movie you know yeah
with my grandma all the time and you
know I went back I went up you know I
went to YouTube and I was just looking
at all this video listen I ran into
smooth criminal' like okay this is sick
we need to do this so I showed my dad
it's like oh I love it let's let's talk
to Joe be my manager and the director
everyone liked it so and then that's
kind of how it happened it's like a JT
and I totally get that it almost has a
little like suit and tie right yeah and
like the it I love it it's so classic we
actually posted a behind-the-scenes look
at that music video to et online which
you guys can go and check out the fans
went nuts what was your favorite part of
doing that music video my favorite part
I think for me I got to be with all my
friends
like and I met new people too so I got
to be like everybody and we just danced
all day when they called cut we were
still dancing and it was just so super
fun and I feel like I was really excited
for the fans to see this song cuz I knew
this one this is my favorite song by far
so and they loved it
they're diggin it they think it's a bob
so that's awesome thank you guys they
love it they don't just like it they're
like hardcore feeling it and I have to
tell you the comments section blew up
people wanting to know your relationship
status so can you set the record
straight yeah I mean so that was really
my first time meeting her so I mean it
was a lot of fun so I mean we're just
friends yeah yeah she's super cool
though I love her family so there's a
lot of fun working with her any girls
outside of the music video well no
comment
comment please the fair enough fair
enough so what's next with the music is
there gonna be a full album coming
hopefully I'm in the studio
I actually am recording a song after
this no way yeah we have lots of new
music coming so hopefully in album's
coming so just be prepared it's gonna be
great yeah be on the lookout guys it's
going to be good and tonight if I'm not
mistaken is the season finale of ant of
Andy yeah it's the finale
I can't believe awesome what can the
fans expect tonight it's going down
that's all I can say I think you guys
are gonna love this episode because this
is I think this is the biggest episode
by far at least for everybody season 3
soon for season 4 season I don't know
see if there was a season four
what would I'd like to see a lot of
things I don't know I think it'd be I
think it'd be cool for Jonah - maybe
like join the basketball team with Buffy
or something like that I think that'd be
cool I love sports so I'm you go to play
like he does love sports where you no
matter before this life started where
does love it and being a part of swoosh
being a part of the Disney family you
know there's all these great people who
have come out of the Disney family is
there anyone that you particularly look
up to you know growing up I've watched
all the High School Musical movies so
like I was a big fan of Zac Efron that's
who I really looked up to so I'd always
watch the movies with my brother and
sister and my dad my mom and I actually
went to Teen Choice yesterday nice oh it
was I think it did see him or meet him
but I saw him on stage when he won so
that was cool watching him give a speech
and I was like people uncommon like when
he got up there he was it just felt like
he was so me and I just he's awesome and
I got to meet you bro I got it I don't
have a lot of comments so shout out I
love it and you right now are you know
juggling this crazy career it's totally
blowing up so awesome but you're also
growing up you're still a kid so what's
the biggest challenge in that I think
the biggest challenge for me
you know I I've been homeschooled since
I was like
fourth grade and like I've just been
working and working and this is what I
want to do for the rest of my life so I
think just getting time to spend with my
family and my friends I think that's
like the most important thing for me
because they've been supporting me my
whole life and my family are making all
this sacrifice sacrifices for me my
brother and my sister I mean we're out
in Utah right now so I just I just want
to stay humble and I'm so glad that I'm
with the right people and working with
the right people
yeah and yes everybody can you go team
his mom and dad are here today and
they're so sweet they're like totally in
it I love it
that's so cute and Shazam talk about
Shazam yes tell me about the moment that
you landed the role because this is a
huge deal um yes it was it was crazy
when I got this audition and I got a
callback it's like okay this is
happening they we know they kind of like
me a little bit I don't know how but um
then I went to my acting coach Rob and I
was like we were psyched we couldn't
believe it we wanted to do this the
right way cuz this I was like this is me
I got to get this I want this so bad and
then I don't know we came in LA for the
test the last stage and I went in I came
out and I was like okay I killed that
yes see what happens and two hours later
we were heading to the airport I was in
the restroom of course he booked it the
bathroom I just see everyone's screaming
I'm like running up and down everyone's
trying to hug me and I just it was
surreal for me that's so awesome as a
family moment yeah definitely so your
mom and dad knew who was the first
person that you told probably my best
friends back home yeah yeah I couldn't I
couldn't tell anybody for two weeks
until it came out on everything two
whole weeks was that like the longest
two weeks I can tell your heart it was
and then once it became public then you
told your friends yeah then I don't I
don't really remember I think I I think
I did it after yeah yeah good for you
that's hard that's like major secret
keeping I could not my lips are way too
big I tell all the secrets so then you
play the same character as Zachary Levi
but you're the younger version so you
guys don't ever actually
share a scene right we don't you don't
know did you guys have some bonding time
though to kind of like figure out what
the character was gonna be like um
definitely I think before we started
filming the David the director we all
went like read the script together yeah
and um he's a funny guy he's perfect for
this role cuz he's literally a kid he's
not even in a dull
um but it was it was super cool getting
to know him and just working with Jackie
was a lot of fun I was a big fan of it
so I was super excited and just the
whole Shazam fan it was so cool and like
this is like my first I don't know like
real movie for me actually it's going to
the theaters it's just crazy guys next
year get ready um but it was super cool
and I can't believe this is actually
happening
yeah this is like surreal awesomeness I
love crazy Zachary give you any tips on
or any advice on set yeah yeah a lot I
think I loved he's just such a great guy
like when we were filming he would just
show just to support us and just watch
us and just talk to us so he's he's
great and I mean I definitely look up to
him he's so funny he's so funny yeah he
looks funny the trailer is like
hilarious he also looks funny yeah I
love it well the fan questions are
flooding in so I figured I should get to
some of these do it
Susan is wanting to know when you'll go
on tour again well let's see Susan yes
hopefully soon hopefully soon awesome
okay then Kenny is wanting he says can
you say hello to Kenny Frederick of West
Jordan Utah I'm a huge superfan of Andy
Mac which was filmed in Utah what do you
like about your character character
Jonah Beck okay first of all what's up
Kenny what's up um what do I like about
Jonah Beck a lot of things I think you
know he's super oblivious you know so I
love playing man because I mean he
doesn't know what's going on yeah and
it's funny when people try to explain it
to him because they still doesn't get it
um I like he's so energetic you're just
so me like he'll just come in just like
what's up guys what's up how you doing
but he's really thoughtful sensitive
he's he's a great guy
kind of
lexi is said what is the most
inspirational thing you can say to your
fans who are trying to reach for the
stars
what's-her-name looks like see ya I
would probably say be courageous be kind
for you that's so good succinct thank
you
how was performing the national anthem
do you get stage fright that was from
econ that was econ that was it was so
cool I was I was kind of nervous not
gonna lie but especially for me it was I
was performing for my home team so I was
super excited and just to be able to
watch the game with all my friends it
was amazing but when I got up there and
I just saw all these people my mind was
I was just blown I couldn't believe it
were you scared you were gonna forget
the lyrics my biggest fear like under
pressure sometimes you just definitely
like this crowd on I know I I knew I had
the lyrics down but my family kept
trying to they did like this thing home
like really like right before I go
onstage you're gonna do that I like it
they're keeping it funny
all right so Emmy says what was it like
working with Annie Leblanc
it was awesome working with Annie the
day we filmed that we'd never met but my
brother and sister are a huge fan of her
so I was like hey that's they love her
let's let's let's see if it works so we
met her it was a lot of fun we filmed
all day we cracked I cracked a lot of
jokes of course cuz that's me yeah you
trying to be funny but she was super
nice and we had a lot of fun that's so
awesome I love it and now that you're a
part of the DC family officially is
there anyone else in that family that
you're dying to work with or meet
maybe gal gadot I would I would say that
but I just I just recently met all of
them at comic-con well most of them you
did okay yeah did you freak out the most
about um go yeah for sure
yeah and command Jason
I couldn't he was like right next to me
and we were talking and his kids I met
his kids and they're a fan of and Emacs
and
awesome that's so cool what did what do
you say to someone like that when you
meet them like what did you say to gal
what did you say to Jason or did you oh
let's see I think I I went I went to go
and I was like hey I'm a sure you may
not know me but I'm in the I'm in a new
movie coming out next year and I'm a big
fan sometime so a big Wonder Woman fan
you know and what did she say I mean she
was very nice she was like of course
let's get you out there defense'll vania
yeah that's like all right Donnie done
book it how many times did you practice
saying Shazam in the mirror so many yeah
so many times I actually did it so many
times at my manager and like my dad they
were just saying it with me I was just
you know what I kind of feel like the
perfect way to end this interview would
to be a straight to camera shows am from
the man himself
[Music]
stand up will stand up let's do it Shh
wait the camera there it is following us
it's following us we're almost there it
is okay let's do it
we're ready you do it and then I'll do
it with you all right all right Sam oh
my gosh that was so good it echoed we
literally heard it in the room awesome
well thank you so much Asher they just
are tuning in we love seeing you we
loved having your comments Asher you're
the best thank you so much guys bye
[Music]
you